[Música]
y llegamos hasta la capital británica
donde sigue la incertidumbre sobre quién
será el nuevo primer ministro de reino
unido conectamos por supuesto con
nuestra corresponsal luisa pulido luisa
la saludo muy buena tarde feliz lunes
muy buen ya a día que transcurre en
reino unido le pregunta entonces cuáles
son estos candidatos que han entrado a
esta carrera por el 10 de downing street
buenas tardes caluroso día aquí en
londres hasta el momento la lista lleva
11 postulados pero puede seguir
creciendo en las próximas horas
probablemente hasta mañana cuando
cierren formalmente las inscripciones
dentro de esta lista están tres
ministros actuales del gabinete tres
ministros de estado la ministra de
exteriores el recién nombrado ministro
de finanzas y también el ministro de
transporte también están los ex
ministros de salud shavit y el ex
ministro de defensa richi sunat quienes
promovieron este terremoto político que
obligó la salida de boris johnson
también está el pen y morgan que es la
primera ministra mujer de defensa de
este país york y mahan que fue el
finalista como les johnson cuando fue
elegido la fiscal general suela
brevemente que mi bandera germán city y
tomada gem hat que es actualmente el
encargado el jefe de la comisión de
exteriores del parlamento británico
luisa le pregunto si en todo esta
elección podemos esperar algún tipo de
cambios en el proceso de elegir a este
primer ministro
si el partido conservador está
determinado en que el proceso sea lo más
rápido lo más expedito posible no de
meses sino de semanas y por ello esta
noche se espera que haya cambios
sustanciales sobre el proceso de
elección entre ellos para que una
candidatura pueda hacer realmente tener
alguna posibilidad en el futuro al menos
20 diputados tendrán que respaldar a un
candidato en este momento son 8 también
se espera que haya rondas de eliminación
cada semana y se espera que los dos
finalistas estén para el 21 de julio
entonces estas dos personas los elegidos
iniciarán durante el verano en agosto
recorridos y giras por todo el país para
que luego las bases del partido
conservador puedan elegirán su nuevo
jefe que por ende será el nuevo primer
ministro británico justamente hoy boris
johnson en su primera aparición desde
que tuvo que renunciar el jueves pasado
dijo que no apoyará públicamente a
ninguno de estos candidatos porque no
quiere perjudicar su candidatura y ha
dicho que está determinado en estas
últimas semanas en downing street a
cumplir con el programa por el que fue
elegido hace tres años